I have another question for you before
we end um why don't you watch Game of
Thrones oh okay so I watched the first
episode and once they threw the kid off
the top of the building I was done
anything with kids really disturbs me
you know when you read about kids
getting you know murdered or you know
molested or something it like that
bothers me you know what more kids die
so kids dying so okay okay so check it
out
so so yeah so I didn't really get to
that first episode when they threw the
kid off the top of the building and then
somebody told me I've had conversations
with that kid ends up he comes back he
lives whatever so then I was on the road
somewhere a couple years later and
flipping through the channels and HBO
there's Game of Thrones razón I thought
you know what I'm gonna give this
another chance I'm gonna sit here they
burned alive a twelve-year-old girl that
was the next one war the mom was okay
with
yeah Shareen terrain yeah yeah so the
only new episode you saw two kids got
her particularly painful actually that
was hard too I know she'd see the
episode where Olly dies yeah yeah yeah
but the show is great if you ever hi I
think I you know I I think I think I'll
start at the beginning and give it a
shot it's really good yeah everybody I'm
obsessed with but you know what I think
is better than Game of Thrones my new
album is recorded 24 cities around the
world it starts in Paris it ends in jury
Wow
there's 40 tracks it's three hours long
some people said why didn't just break
it up into three albums no this is the
concept for the album Wow so there's
there's three Paris tracks you know it's
three Hong Kong tracks now how do you
know you know that they're there in Hong
Kong do they laugh differently or do you
say that there aren't Hong Kong at the
beginning I how do you know you're Hong
Kong well like at the beginning you know
you said yeah hello Hong Kong oh you see
hallo Hong Kong yes maybe you could be
easier anyway you can probably you mean
tell but just by the laughs what country
they're in well there's a lot of there's
a lot of times a lot of Scandinavia
Berlin yeah and you think I think it's
great and I'm gonna plug it in a sec
it's the best so you're doing and what
you're doing right now and you're
squeezing in but the thing is is that I
have some other questions okay oh okay
you said we were about to say goodbye
we're not saying goodbye because you had
one more question for me and that really
so I got you were rushing me I'm not
rushing you I'm not gonna rush you out
oh good I were to go just that so you
feel miserable I'm the only no no no
oh she can [ __ ] kalila I'll make you
great I'll make a chick no you're not
making your chicken bones for nobody
alright so that you film this around the
world it's audio I recorded it
no [ __ ] it's audio Tom but you said
filmed it you said you
[Music]